hey guys it's Jan here I know we're all
really excited to see Ryan Reynolds play
the iconic Deadpool in his own movie so
I wanted to take a look at ten things
you probably didn't know about the film
and just before I kick off I've got an
awesome giveaway so if you'd like a
chance to win some cool Deadpool merch
make sure you subscribe and comments
about the movie on this video for more
details and ways to enter the comp check
out the gleam link in the video
description below right now for those
Deadpool movie facts to reduce Deadpool
scarred look makeup department head bill
Corso created thin semi-transparent
silicone prosthetics that showed muscles
blood and tissue under the skin it took
around four hours to get Ryan Reynolds
ready and he wore ten of those super
thin silicone prosthetics on his head
and for one scene even had them applied
all over his body
according to Reynolds the prosthetics
felt like he was wearing a wet diaper on
his face the character of Colossus was
super strong and super tall is mostly
computer-generated with the aid of a
motion capture performance and the fact
that his steel like armored form is
completely reflective was quite a
challenge for the filmmakers to solve
the problem they used a 3d camera system
to capture all the action that takes
place around Colossus then they placed
that action onto Colossus his body as a
reflection so for example when Deadpool
runs around Colossus we see the
reflection of Deadpool on his mutant
allies metal body speaking of Colossus
actor Daniel Cudmore who played the
character in x-men - The Last Stand and
Days of Future past was offered the part
the Deadpool but turned it down as not
only as the character computer-generated
was also the filmmakers wanted to use
another actors voice for the part in the
end Colossus is played by three actors
in Deadpool under a trick etre did the
motion capture regular salad the facial
motion capture the 7 kappa chick
provided the voice of colossus when it
came to Deadpool's fight scenes the
filmmakers wanted to combine badass
stunts with playful wisecracking
so Ryan Reynolds took cues from none
other than heavyweight boxing great
Muhammad Ali not only in terms of Ali's
moves in the ring was also with regards
to Ali's technique of trash-talking his
opponents both before and during a match
in fact actor ed skrein has said that
the clashes between his character Ajax
and Deadpool in the movie a reminiscent
of Muhammad Ali versus Joe Fraser stunts
coordinated Philip Silvera created a
hybrid style for scenes where Deadpool
fights with his signature katanas the
style mixes tactical thinking Japanese
and Chinese sword work and the kind of
strikes used in Filipino martial arts
and speaking of Deadpool's katella's Rai
men also said on Twitter that his name's
and Bea and Arthur presumably because in
the comic books the Merc with a mouth
just happens to be a huge fan of actress
Bea Arthur who starred in TV comedy The
Golden Girls Ryan Reynolds spent six
months in the gym getting beefed up to
play Deadpool and actually threw his
back out on the first day of training
first by the time he came to wear his
costume his muscles were so big that
they had to remove the muscle layer in
the suit many superhero suits have a
polyurethane type muscle suit underneath
to add definition on camera bursts
according to director Tim Miller and
Ryan Reynolds when Reynolds put on the
suit with the muscle layer underneath it
looked over the top so they removed it
to give Reynolds more the classic
Deadpool look when Reynolds finished
filming Deadpool memories of the shoot
weren't the only thing he took with him
in fact the actor swiped one of his
Deadpool costumes which he reckons he
more than earned after waiting 10 years
to finally make the movie Deadpool maybe
r-rated but apparently there was still
some stuff that was deemed just too
offensive to make it into the final Kurt
one particular bar scene featuring Ryan
Reynolds and TJ Miller as Deadpool and
his pal weasel was cut down because
according to director Tim Miller it went
too far and was particularly mean and
offensive to so many people but even the
final cut of the movie proved too much
for China where the movies been refused
permission to screen in cinemas due to
its violence nudity and graphic language
the character of negasonic teenage
warhead who's played by brianna
hildebrand was created by comic book
writer Grant Morrison and named after
the song negasonic teenage warhead by
the band Monster Magnet warhead first
appeared back in 2001 in the new x-men
comic books
Deadpool screenwriters represen Paul
Wernick said that they were given a pre
proofed list of characters they could
use for the movie and as soon as they
saw the name negasonic teenage warhead
they just had to use it form a mixed
martial artist gina carano certainly
isn't afraid of doing her own stunts in
movies like haywire and Deadpool but
there's one thing she does absolutely
detest and that spiders when filming a
fight scene between Colossus and Cora
knows character angel dust the MMA star
turned actress spent a considerable
amount of time getting thrown around in
the dirt as a junkyard getting the
messiest she's ever been in a brawl but
the main thing on her mind throughout
the shoot was whether the crew had
actually done a spider check before they
started filming now or see you most
excited about for the Deadpool movie and
what would you like to see in a sequel
let me know in the comments below I've
got more deadpool videos on the way
including a movie review and an easter
egg video and i'll add annotations here
when they're live and don't forget to
subscribe and leave a comments about the
movie on this video for a chance to win
some awesome Deadpool merch for more
details and ways to enter the comp check
out the gleam link in the video
description below thanks for watching
and see you next time yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers